the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I am Ryan sickler Ryan
sickler.com and Ryan sickler and all
your social media every week I want to
say thank you I'm very grateful for what
I do and thank you guys please subscribe
to this channel it helps I'm telling you
we get limited everything over here my
specials pulled out of that algorithm I
keep telling you guys we talk about real
stuff over here YouTube isn't a fan of
some of the words that are used on this
show but it's an important show and
we're going to keep doing it all right
so make sure you subscribe check out the
special if you gotta have more check out
the patreon it's called the Honeydew
with y'all and it's the wild I'm telling
you for five dollars it's one of the
best buys you're gonna get on patreon
the stories are insane it's the Honeydew
with y'all we just had a lady who uh was
a victim of an attempted double murder
slash suicide uh I guess it's a murder
suicide she ducked the husband shot you
hit her in the Carotid artery another
bullet goes through her mouth through
her jaw and outer neck she is paralyzed
and she is alive and she looks fantastic
and she is on there telling her story
tons of stuff like that it's five bucks
a month I'm telling you go check it out
and if you're looking for a new podcast
to listen to go check out the crab Feast
it is a
it's a great Library it's 300 and some
episodes and it's got everybody you love
on it Bill Burr Burke Chrysler Tom segor
Christina P everybody's on that thing
and and it's Evergreen it's stories you
could listen to Forever today's guest
has great episodes on the crab Feast
come catch me on tour we just added some
more dates and we're adding more July
7th and 8th is Appleton Wisconsin August
18th and 19th I'm gonna be in Tampa
Florida that's actually that's the first
time I've done stand up in Florida since
I went with uh sagora years and years
ago Springfield Missouri September 1st
and 2nd coming to you Springfield Tulsa
we're back on the books tall so they're
open now September 15th and the 16th and
we're adding more and more for the rest
of the year and all of next year go get
your tickets at ryansickler.com now
that's the biz you know what we're doing
over here we're highlighting the low
lights with you all and uh these are the
stories behind the storytellers I'm very
excited to have this guest back on the
Honeydew ladies and gentlemen please
welcome Sam tripley welcome back
it's good to be here I love you brother
I love you and that is a great that's a
great hoodie that's a great hoodie dude
all my heroes are shadowbank go Tim fall
head t-shirts.com well before we get
into what I wanted to start talking to
you about I can't believe you haven't
been to Florida in Forever it's the best
comedy bro it's the best thing I'm gonna
be doing Miami at some point down
Miami's a great scene now we're going to
do I have to be garbage now it's the
best and then you just go down and you
hang out on South Beach and it's like
Grand Theft Auto Doc
you may not sell take it down there
because who wants to go watch it a 50
year old tell jokes when you go watch
Grand Theft Auto dog yeah hey just sit
there and watch pretty people
that's Miami dude it's it's the it's the
Latin San Diego San Diego is the white
Miami that's where I'm going right now
but you know what I'm saying so it's
like have fun in Florida is the best
Tampa all right so you got La La's La
then Vegas is Blue Collar LA and then
Tampa is scumbag Vegas
[Laughter]
it's the best
I'd move there
uh well before we get into everything
plug and promote everything please thank
you dude uh go to samtripley.com
for all everything Sam tripley all my
videos on my podcast if you love
storytelling I got a podcast called
broken simulation where I just basically
talk about my week and it it started
during covid and like all the comedy
clubs shut down so I started a podcast
where I could work bits and then it just
became a wonderful podcast and like I
was walking down Hollywood Boulevard
during coven and just watching people go
nuts so it's uh it's called broken
simulation it's about two hours every
week I just talk about my life and then
you know I have Tim fall hat I'm famous
for and then my show for with Brian
Collins called uh Conspiracy social club
and it's uh people love it so go check
out samtripley.com you'll find it all
well I'm I'm known you for I mean since
the 1900s bro and
um still to this day I always say it the
the wheelchair the dead leg stripper in
the wheelchair is one of the the
absolute best physical acts out act outs
I've ever seen man I I used to look
around by myself and look at other
people like his legs look dead they're
dead
dude I wrote that bit when I was about
23 years old man I'm 50 dude you can't
do that that [__]
I'm like if I go down I don't come back
yeah you'll be in a wheel
for sure dude that's a young man's [__]
that is a young man
young man because you would flail you
would hit the girl hard not what I am
thinking about doing is after I do this
next special I'm about to shoot called
weirdo uh-huh I'm thinking about doing a
Greatest Hits and going back through all
of my stuff and just putting together
the my favorite bits into one special
and I'm gonna do some stuff with that
but so that's the stuff you have
recorded all the stuff because there's
some jokes to all of mine well well
there's all my old videotapes all my old
everything and I took it to um a place
in like by the airport where they
destroy it why you can watch it on
camera I took my daughter I was like
let's go watch because it's I know what
it is
like it's all stuff where I worked on I
ended up releasing it and what I felt
was its best version you know my album
yeah my special so after that gone Purge
it get rid of that [__] but I have some
albums that probably not a lot of people
have listened to I'm not talking about
an album I'm talking about sets you know
where I'm working on yeah yeah yeah
that's all yeah these kids don't
understand they got phones we got
cassettes bro they're a thick like a
book y'all got a vhsc the compact
100 I was so dumb so I did a I did a uh
a sketch comedy show with Duncan
Trussell Brian Jarvis Jason Tebow and
myself it was called the stupid dummies
and I was such an idiot we filmed it and
it was like very Advanced it was like
one of the first ones to do like kind of
this like kind of hipster comedy at the
time it was like very weird unrelatable
but super funny and we recorded on a
tape MTV's like hey we'd like to hear it
we'd like to see the stuff I sent them
the tape I didn't make any copies of it
it was I sent them that I was the only
one the only one oh no
of course not God it's somewhere in MTV
right now or it's trash yeah like an
idiot we didn't we weren't I had to make
copies I never did it yeah because you
had to have two of those machines to do
that or take it somewhere to do that and
each copy was like five bucks it was
like four uh these kids have it so easy
now so speaking of kids this is what I
wanted to talk about you're a single dad
of twins twin girls twin girls two baby
girls three years I'm a single dad of a
girl but my father was a single dad of
twins also
um we had a young we had my younger
brother as well so three total but I
want to talk to you about what that's
like because especially in a city like
Los Angeles it's not cheap to live here
you've got two miles to feed you got
double everything diapers all of it yeah
so what was it like when you first heard
you were having a baby and how and did
you find out it was twins how fast
I found out it was twins when we went to
go get the sonogram okay and you know
what's funny I don't mean interrupt but
I never once even con I'm a twin I when
we went in I never even considered twins
when the lady said oh I only hear one
heartbeat my heart dropped I was like oh
I didn't even think about there could
have been two or three or something in
there so you know obviously at the time
you guys are pregnant you go in for a
sonogram and I I don't know there's two
kids I wasn't told there was two kids I
just knew that somebody was pregnant
okay
somebody's pregnant did somebody know
there were two in there already I don't
know you're not just I don't know all
right I remember going in and then
they're doing the song crap and then
they're like there's a and there's B and
I go there's a b dude I'm like Oh my God
I'm gonna be dad to two
oh my God like like I can't explain this
like zero to a hundred miles an hour
that's what it is and in my mind I had
the exact opposite effect I was like
whoa I'm only gonna be a dad to one
I don't even understand it because I
just did a show in Baton Rouge and a
woman who's a fan of mine she had
triplets no no clue what that means so
forever my opinion is for every one
child you need an extra adult so if you
have one kid you need two adults if you
have two kids you need three adults and
if you have triplets you need a village
to raise these kids extended family
friends with all of it did you ever wait
tables yeah okay the tables and busts so
let me tell you what it's like to have
twins it's basically your section is
slammed 24 hours a day that's what it is
you're cleaning your own everything
everything dude so what was really crazy
is like we we lived in the the valley at
that time in Valley Village and she
wanted to have give birth at Cedar Sinai
in Beverly Hills
yeah so I'm like we're almost die I'm
like what if we're way over here and the
water breaks and we gotta get way over
there and I'm like I have to be Jack
Bauer from 24 and I gotta get across L.A
in like 30 happen during rush hour or
yeah right it better happen to 3 A.M
yeah so I'm I'm uh I'm always a crazy I
was a crazy person back then you know
I'm sober now I got like tomorrow will
be two years in six months right but I
you know I was a crazy person and I I
admit I was pissing the mom off by being
an idiot you know there was a lot of
pressure going on right
so my whole fears that I'm gonna have to
drive this woman with her water breaks
across LA to get there in time so I
don't bring these kids into the world
because I do I have no clue what I'm
doing right so we go to you know how
they have that class where you have to
um where they teach you how to be take
care of newborns you go to that yeah
well we go to that at the hospital yeah
yeah and she's we're at we're at
Cedars-Sinai she's pissed at me because
I'm being an idiot right she's already
pissed at me she's like can I see you
outside I go oh man she's gonna lay into
me right here at the hospital
so she goes outside she goes I think my
water broke I'm like what I just got so
excited I go what yeah we're already
here dude I was so excited we were
already in the hospital perfect she goes
into labor right there dude wow yep so
we were already at the hospital I'm like
Zippity dude
this is the best case scenario for me
right so she's in the hospital
she's giving birth and I got really
lucky dude because
they were still allowing peop fathers in
the uh the birth room
okay they were still allowing them in
because right after this covet hits oh
it's right and dads can't be be in the
delivery room
so I get really was that right yeah dude
there was a ton of moms giving birth to
kids with no but also a ton of dads that
don't get to even be in that room
because of coven and see their kid born
yeah I didn't know it was going down
like that it was crazy right it was
crazy so so it's coming and like she
gets in there pretty quick and we walk
in and just like when you when you're in
the Opera or the the uh delivery room
there's a million people in that room
and then you start going am I paying for
everybody here
why are there 50 nurses and 10 doctors
we can we cut a bunch of cards every
time you come in this room for everybody
here
am I paying for everybody here so she's
giving she's giving birth she's doing a
great job it's taking a while
and the nurse goes the nurse goes yeah
it's taking a long time it's pretty
tight and I go exactly bro right because
it's like that's why I'm here I'm trying
to high-five everybody
yeah that's why we're here dude tight as
hell bro tight as hell
she's like stop making jokes bro so her
biggest fear was that with twins she was
gonna have to give Canal birth and then
they were gonna have to do the cut open
till the C-section and then as sure as
[__] the so they're like the first baby
comes and it's so funny about having
kids is that my daughters
are their exact personalities that they
are right now when they came out
the first baby
comes out they're like the first one's
coming and she just hits the hole
the camel in this High stepping right
out of the hole bro boom just hits it
you see why it's like Bo Jackson when he
hits yeah yeah
linebackers are flying everywhere bang
she's our she's like I'm here bam she
came out real early
hahaha
and that is her personality and we'll
get into all that so the second baby's
like I paid rent for the whole month I'm
staying
so she jackknifes in the back she like
pushes back it's like in Jujitsu shrimp
roll like it pushes back
dude everybody in that room surrounds
her like she just robbed a bank and they
got her cornered and they're like you
better come out now we got is it yeah we
got you surrounded she's like I ain't
coming out anywhere right so literally
like like five Asian doctors have their
hands up there trying to pull this kid
out well while I'm meeting my other
daughter who is like not crying not just
hanging out over here
they're trying to get the baby out they
get the baby out I look oh my God it's
my baby I look back down
and I'm looking at my baby I go back out
and they got they got the baby's mama
and they're like where does this piece
go where it was like Build-A-Bear right
they had a they had to put it back
together again oh
the worst bro and she took it like a
champ man women I'm telling you I know
there's no doubt no been in the room
so we so we have two kids man and it's
crazy and
you how long do they let you stay in the
hospital with twins we were pretty much
in and out of there no we were in and
out you get like one overnight and then
you're out we were out they put them
under the lights to make sure everything
was okay and we were out you know what I
didn't even think about too is um when
they came in they said would you and
um Dad like a rest we can take the baby
we'll give her a bath put her under some
light wall and we were like yeah yeah
and then like a friend of ours like you
let them take the baby you get the wrong
one back and stuff I was like what they
start scaring you and [__] like that I'm
like I don't even think of that I would
just let them take the baby but these
are the people you should let take the
baby right right and my kids the first
baby looks exactly like her mother it's
the same face and the second one looks
exactly like my mom so we got the the
right kids and it's so funny because she
got so mad at me because she's going
into labor and I'm like sleeping on the
side I love that they're like we're
gonna give you in the data a a little
break like you were just oh my God
yes did you do anything with the blood
that they they like oh we'll take the
blood I'll tell you what I saw
um I've talked about this on my album
where I I legit I didn't I didn't think
I was partaking I was told I was gonna
be behind her head with uh you know the
blanket up where I couldn't see anything
I'm seeing what she sees and they were
like nope get around here and they
wanted me to hold her leg and I had to
hold her leg and then I'm seeing it all
go down and it didn't hit me like it did
on TV when it's yours it just it wasn't
it wasn't gross now you're just in that
adrenaline mode of I want everything to
be okay is she breathing or all her
fingers until you know what I mean is
everything happening right here you know
because I don't know if that's happening
right
and um she comes out and they tell me to
cut the umbilical cord well my daughter
I guess she pooped in her mom's womb and
it's called meconium I think yes so they
said we need you to cut that cord
immediately because she can't cry if she
cries she could ingest the poop in her
lungs and that's a big deal so I'm over
there trying to I talk about I'm trying
to get there I was gonna get like some
real medical grade [__] I said yeah
and I [__] gave her over and then
they they
um like just basically vacuumed her out
real quick and boom she was good to go
but that was a little bit and then
I turned back around now
I didn't know about the placenta until
sex ed in high school and it's I'm not
even joking when I tell you we watched a
woman give birth and then the after
birth comes out and everyone's in class
like what is that and they're laughing
like that's the after birth that's
placenta whatever we have lunch next we
got I'm not joking we got lunch next
I've never forgot it
uh back in the day before phones I used
to read on the toilet all the time
that's how I learned they would put
placenta and shampoo like if there was
nothing to read uh yeah young kids you'd
read the bag of toothpaste anything and
I learned that they put placenta because
of the protein I guess and everything in
some shampoos
um so I'm waiting to see that
I'm waiting to see it I know it's coming
you're waiting for them to scoop it into
shampoos yeah I've been trying to get
Sean Johnson to make me a deal right
there I like this one so Herbal Essence
might do we'll give you top dollar
that's why they're doing this in the
commercials they're just placentas
flying up all over the place and I'm
holding my daughter and looking at her
and I'm just looking back I'm waiting to
see I want to see them deliver this
placenta make sure everything's okay and
right before they do this gush of I
don't know what fluid hits this nurse in
the chest like God she just takes one
rocks back she looks at the other nurse
with this look and I was like
like knocked her back and she looked at
the nurse leg and she's like she hadn't
seen it before you know what I mean like
what the [__] like some saw [__] like
just blood just just
wow all kinds of like after birth fluid
and just uh just poof I never wanted
at the hall
I'm like kind of doing it over the top I
wanted to see my baby's first breath and
then that's it I didn't want to see what
happened to the city and then you know
because you're in the city because
you're you're you know your ladies your
ladies bit Parts go from like San Diego
to San Francisco real quick right let's
get down you should be pristine real
estate
now I need to like some serious work
yeah dude all right so now you go home
we get home as
a dad to two girls it's crazy so so
what's really funny is like your family
starts calling you because you're a girl
Dad they start giving you advice and I
talk about this in my ACT they start
giving you advice on how to take care of
girls and my cousin Lisa is like do you
know how you wipe girl bot and I go no
how do you wipe girl but she goes you go
vagina back and then I go Lisa how do
you think men wipe their asses
do you think we're going [__] tonight
and pulling up like what do you think
we're doing I bet you some dudes do I'll
bet you that's why women are like that
guy's balls thing I bet you there are
dudes that [__] wipe back to front
and get like
junk true
that's the first thing I watch and then
I shampoo my [__] that's how I do I
get in there yeah but I've also been
getting my [__] shaved down dude it's
best [__] you'll ever take in your life
when you get a get your b-hole shaved
down will you get waxed did you fart and
you're like all the anal hairs help
break the fart yeah they do you don't
realize that you're totally right now
you got this bubble word
effective anal hairs actually
it's another lie it's a lie
it's the big waxing complex that's
convinced you the wax your bill
oh yeah your farts are different man
bubble up and just ride up yeah
it feels really uncomfortable
it's different it is man
so so you get your kids home and and the
biggest craziest thing is that they
never tell you about burping
like people go what is the most
traumatic part
and it's it's burping burping to me why
because you like they're so tiny and you
don't know if they burped or not so
you're just sitting there like hitting
this kid at some point it's like was
that a burp was that not a burp am I
just beating the [__] out of this kid
right now this kid's bad because you
could burp forever it could take for us
that to me was the most traumatizing
thing was that it was burping and like
the one thing that was really cool about
the whole covet thing if there was
anything cool it was like it forced me
to be home my kids which was a real
great experience instead of having to go
out and work all the time you know I
could work from home and be with my kids
and and we got to spend a lot of time
together so you know so I so I get us a
house and like I remember growing up in
my my my my my
house that I grew up in in Cortland New
York and we had one bathroom
and my dad had this amazing ability to
know right when I wanted to take a
shower and he would just walk in there
and just napom the entire bathroom I
mean just drop dirty bombs paint would
peel and all that [__] right and I would
have to go in and shower in my dad's
[__] fast right but I was like no this
isn't gonna happen so I I was able to
find a a a a house with two bedrooms so
we moved them in it's really great they
got a kid's bedroom uh and it's amazing
to like raise these kids but you know
then they start getting a little a
little older and then they become you
know they're toddlers or I call them
antifa right yeah because they're
domestic terrorists all they want to do
is burn down your entire they just want
to destroy the the the patriarchy that's
all they want to do and like they would
know when their mom was leaving because
the mom would be like can I just get a
nap I'm like yeah go get a nap take a
nap and then as soon as their mom left
they would just look at me with this
like devilish look in their eye grab
something throw it down smash it running
around they like spray painted BLM on my
refrigerator
for a second I was like wait
shit's burning part of the house is
burning
like [__] the patriarchy yeah so it was
like it was like kind of crazy man to
have kids and like
it just changed me I just became a
different person you know it was it's
like I I quit doing drugs in what ways
yeah tell me
I wanted a girl because I knew it would
calm me down well it gave me a different
point of view on things where I knew it
would just soften me in a way that I
knew I needed and I didn't think
anything else was gonna do it it got me
sober you know like I really got sober
because there was a couple times where I
you know couldn't take the pressure
and I I I went out
and I felt so low and I remember just
making a decision one day ago and they
these kids didn't pick this they didn't
ask for this and you know I have a goal
in my life with my kids I don't know if
it's possible I just don't want to be
the reason they're in therapy that's my
only goal in life is like I just want to
surround them with love encourage them
to be the best be the right kind of
discipline where it's it's they know I'm
doing it out of love and just try to get
them to a team where they don't go and
go my Dallas deck and he didn't love me
and he didn't do I that's my whole goal
in life and I felt like if I continued
down this path I was going to be the
reason they were in therapy and so I got
sober and I remember calling a friend of
mine one day and
I just gone out and he was like okay Sam
you know you keep doing this you're
trying to do sobriety you're trying to
build Rome in a day
you gotta take it in 24 hour increments
and that's kind of when I work with
people in recovery that's why I say it's
like don't do this don't try to do
everything in a day
it's only about 24 hours so it gave me
this little prayer that I would say when
I I will really start getting like like
uh itchy right where I really wanted my
my whenever I wanted to do drugs my body
would start like kind of vibrate
and start the hum and I knew like oh man
I want to go out and he gave me this
little prayer that just was like and I
tell this newcomers all the time it's
about like you know it's uh ask God like
God I don't want to use today maybe
tomorrow maybe tomorrow use but not
today just give me 24 hours and tomorrow
if I use we'll deal with it then and
then I started saying that and I started
putting together these days and I got to
like that you know it's like sobriety's
like poker the more days you get the
more chips you got the less like you're
gonna go in a bad hand so I start to
raise these kids and we start to um I
love them and then we're coming up with
names right for the kids we had it
before they were born and we're having a
real debate on like what the name's
gonna be and I do joke about this how
there's like there's rules
like the first rule is you cannot name
your daughters like boys are easy to
name it's like it's after the dad the
grandpa your favorite black athlete
right yeah
there's a boy it was Bo Jackson or
Patrick Ewing I'm dying on that hill
right
but girls are different there's rules
and rule number one you cannot name your
daughters after any woman the mother
doesn't like and that is every woman
she's ever met in her life yeah every
woman
Sarah [__] right uh Tina [__] right
he's like you can't do and then guys you
cannot name your daughters after any
adult film star you've jerked off to
those names are off the list too all the
Russian names are gone all the Russian
name okay so we willed it down my
daughters names are ghost and ninja
Tripoli that's legit uh that's their
middle name okay yeah but that's what
yeah but that's what they go by ghost
ninja all right goes to ninja because
Japanese anime is still on though and
your your daughter's mom is okay with
that no she calls him by the real
you said no so fast
is she okay with you calling them that
though yeah she's okay with it I know
right now everyone thinks it's weird but
I know when they get older they're gonna
love those names and their names fit
them very much they're two different
styles of people what do your families
think of the names they're fine with it
they think it's funny they send me
shirts with their names on it and they
love it and it's a blessing and it's so
crazy as you watch you bring home
literally a meat wad that's what you're
bringing home is just a bundle of meat
that's all it is
and then you start to slowly watch this
the most amazing part the first six
months is just crazy especially with
twins it's go time all the time and then
mom's dealing with everything's going on
with her body the mom did a great job
she had to deal with me too so she
probably had to deal with three crazy
kids but she did a great job and you
just start to watch them download new
operating systems as they go you watch
them start clocking your fingers it's
like such an amazing thing and it's a
love that you will never you can't
understand until you have kids agreed
you'll never understand this nope
if let's say you have a puppy and you
love this puppy so much the minute you
have a kid that puppy's number two and
there's nothing that puppy can do to
compete with the love of the child it's
just something you'll never understand
and it's just changed my life and it
makes me want to be a better person you
know and represent them the best I can
based on my internet I don't know how
I'm doing them with that
they're gonna go back and watch
something oh they're gonna go back and
watch I think about that too like my
daughter's gonna go back and hear every
drug story I've ever told every police
story you know what I mean everything
sneaking out all of it there's no way
I'm gonna be able to be any kind of
person other than honest and fair I like
fair but firm uh but she's gonna be able
to be like well you said you drank I'm
like just stop listening to the [__]
honey doing the crappies all right yeah
and it's so funny because like my mom
always gives me advice on how to raise
kids and I'm and I appreciate it but I'm
like you could also beat us if you
wanted to that was on the table to smack
us around and when you're growing up you
think you're just gonna beat your kids
you're like I'll just I mean you see
people acting up at the airport you'll
be like oh dude you see a kid acting up
with some parent you're like should I go
over there and help that parents and
smack the [__] out of that kid
but when you're older you can't do it
and you have your own kids you can't do
it I'm looking forward to this summer
we'll be hanging out with the kids the
live and the live tour is off and
running we got some dates coming up all
throughout the summer and when you're on
the go like I'll be nothing is more
important than being comfortable staying
cool and looking good while you do it
which is exactly why I love and wear my
doer pants for any occasion uh so doer
sent me a pair of pants and a shirt all
right I've worn both I love them they're
like soft Chinos
man I you if you see me on stage at The
Comedy Store black pants that's the
doers I'll be honest and they gave me a
t-shirt that I was like I don't know at
first because I'm just worried that
those t-shirts they don't always look
flattering on this body you know what I
mean money money doer do her stretch
performance Denim and lifestyle apparels
made for the doers they combine comfort
with style and quality for all we do in
a day and make it designed to last the
technical fabric is breathable
lightweight and durable and not only
does doer look great but we can feel
good about supporting the brand their
clothing is made from sustainable
materials like wood chips plants and
recycled plastic bottles get your own
pair of doer pants to stay cool and
comfortable this summer check out doers
Flagship stores in La and Denver or shop
online at shopdoer.com my listeners will
get 15 off site-wide using my special
promo code honeydew for 15 off your
order go now to shop
d-u-e-r.com and use my special promo
code honeydew shopdoer.com promo code
honeydew now let's get back to the do
and uh so my dad used to do something
called a wink and a nod have I have
talked about this I don't remember if I
talked about but my dad has some called
a wink and a nod where he would never
hit us if my brother acted up he'd give
me a wink and a knot and that man he got
to beat the crap out of my brother bro I
told my stepson that if
we if he had a little brother
and the brother was bugging the [__] out
of me yeah I would do exactly that I'd
just give him the nod he could go
[__] him up yeah and then I'd be like
dare come on man I'd do that
I told him we'd have that agreement and
then when we found out he was having a
Sister he got bummed out I go don't
worry you're gonna we're gonna do that
to every boyfriend yeah for sure
so the kids were shut down forever
during uh covid um and they weren't able
to socialize so once things started
opening up
I used to really love to take into I
love taking my kids to Kids Park yeah
and it's so funny because you know like
whenever you hear people talk about like
um
you know people are basically good I'm
like you've never been to the kids park
because you go to Kidz Bop you realize
it's Lord of the Flies very quickly
yeah like if there were no adults there
they would be sacrificing the autistic
kid trust me on that one
it would just be to moloch you know what
I'm saying so
uh I get there and I love hanging out
with the kids and it's very funny
because like my one daughter she's three
but she runs with six-year-olds which is
both cool and scary at the same time
right and so like I'll be hanging out
with my one daughter pushing her uh on
the I think it will ninja I'll be
pushing Ninja on the swing and ghosts
will be running around and she runs with
older kids
and one day I'm just watching these kits
are like way older way bigger
I'm like I don't know about this I'm
gonna keep an eye on it of course I
don't I'm pushing my kids so I look up
in these two Pakistani girls have my kid
in the air like they're about to
sacrifice her to some Pagan God right
like throw a dumb thing and now I
suddenly understood every single Liam
Neeson movie I've ever watched in my
[__] world yeah yeah every movie I've
ever watched in my life
I got this I got this protector and I'm
like no I start scream right in the
middle thing and I run up and they set
her down and I'm like are you okay
munchkin and suddenly I hear one of them
going and you know okay munchkin and
then I just go in Heckle kill mode and I
just start lighting these kids up
suddenly I hear this really yell large
this guy yelling and I look over and
this tweaker is walking right next
to through the kids right next to the uh
to the uh uh fence by the playground and
he's tweaking hard and he's like
and I'm like oh [__] I look over all the
moms are looking at me they're like you
gotta go go deal with it I go what
happened to feminism man
so I start to uh I I start to walk up
and I start hearing what he's saying and
what the funniest part is is that my kid
is just staring at at the guy tweaking
and going hey my daddy does that [__]
right like my daddy looks [__] weird
and I go okay we don't need to say that
loud all right so I'm walking I'm
watching as I start hearing what he's
saying he starts talking about the
Federal Reserve and how everything is
based off fractional Reserve Banking and
how that's the root of all evil and now
I got a real problem
because I can't shut him down because
he's talking about the truth right
now oh [__] over there
he gets it
or my Facebook and my YouTube oh my God
sent to this guy
so
I come up with an idea I go I pull out a
20 bill in my mind
I go hey man
you're scaring everybody but my kid okay
but my kid
is this my kid's first rodeo okay
I go hey
if I give you this money will you go
away
he goes well I go I'll give you 20 bucks
just go away he grabs a runoff I go you
[__] chill get that [__] Federal
Reserve money right there you [__]
liar right so then he runs off and he's
still walking around
and then the mom so mom's like hey I'm
gonna go my car can you watch me like
I'm supposed to do something
so she walks through his car
she walks to his car her car and I see
him eyeing her and start to walk up and
he looks at me and I just give him the
[__] just point out point at them not
today brother and he walked away and I
saved the day and I was a superhero of
that fight oh yeah yeah that's how it
goes bro that's about how it is to be a
dad I just end up protecting my kids and
what scares you the most
what scares me the most that they'll be
their dad and they'll go out and do
stupid [__] I look at like
I'm losing so many friends to like
fentanyl bro
I'm so blessed I got out when I did yeah
and it's like super sad
and I just don't want them to go through
what all do all the stupid stuff because
if I was running gutting now I probably
wouldn't be here you wouldn't I just
lost First Multiple friends in a week
bro in a week from from that stop that
that really scares me and I I guess I've
already had to talk with my daughter
about it she was seven when we started
talking about fentanyl because a friend
of ours daughter
um died from it and when he visited you
know he's crying I'm crying she's like
what happened then I was like you know
what I'm gonna tell you it's on the back
of buses now and it should be it's it's
so different than it was I know it makes
you sound like Oh Our Generation ever
but this is this is different they're
poisoning everything out there right now
yeah I agree yeah and uh it's it's just
super dangerous
and the only reason I like to do Coke
because
just women like to get weird on it so I
was like let's do it but like what's the
point of that if you're gonna die die
you're gonna die I like I I I'm so funny
I was that I was at a comedy club one
time it was like during one of the
holidays it was a Big Show and I'm in
the back and this chick just starts
cutting up Coke what right there in
front of everybody I go this is how long
I haven't done drugs I'm like what is
happening
she's like yeah I go and then I felt
like defiant about it too I was like
what is this Fear Factor bro are you
gonna do Fear Factor and see if you die
from this stuff and go aren't you
worried about my aren't you worried
about drugs I mean aren't you worried
about Fentanyl and she's like well I got
a bad [__] for a deal I'm like your bad
[__] gonna give you a bad batch man
everyone says the same thing no no I got
the guy at it I'm like okay I bet you
all those people thought they had the
guy yeah yeah I just like I'm so happy
I'm out of it man I remember back in the
day I once saw Doug Stan about The
Comedy Store he's doing a show and I
love Doug samp he's he like for as crazy
as he is on stage and all crazy so he's
the nicest dude you'll ever meet off
stage he's so lovable
and like he he kicked off the the Las
Vegas comedy scene so he kind of started
it and then I got in there and then I
built it up and now it's like a really
great scene
so I I know Doug from Vegas and I
remember going going backstage with him
at the comedy store and dude he did a
line so long
I mean dude when I say it's this long
I'm not lying to you I'm like and I was
a drug addicted I'm like how are you
talking on stage
it's crazy dude so yeah man having kids
are great I take them to uh I take him
to a lot of these kids parks uh and do
you ever go indoor kids park with your
kids yeah I've been there well the
Armenians got that [__] locked down in
in the valley it's all our most oh is
that right oh my people they run
everything dude
so I went to this one the kids Empire
and dude one day
Serena Williams comes in
and she's her and she has like three
handlers per each kid so she's got a
whole village with her with these kids
and I'm telling you bro
that is the first time I've ever seen a
viking in my life
dude she is a [__] Viking bro she's
got the biggest peach I've
I've on a human being in my life a
tennis but that tennis butt is the most
amazing thing you like that is some like
seven most amazing things in the world
it was so big and I just thought like
even if I could hook up with her I
couldn't even get close enough for her
feel anything
[Laughter]
I can't do it
even if she gave me a shot at it
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man
um all right wait I want to uh there's a
couple other things I want to talk about
I I because I do want to switch it up a
little bit I wanted to what's this um
so you said something happened with
Machine Gun Kelly at the comedy stuff
okay I want to hear this story because
this was I saw pictures of him uh at the
store and so I know it wasn't that long
ago no it was only a couple months ago
was it at your show yeah okay so he
showed up to see who Whitney coming okay
so he showed so he's a big fan of
Whitney's and he decided to show up and
come to the show did you know he was
coming no no heads up even right was the
show started no okay I think somebody
said oh hey Machine Gun Kelly's in the
back okay right he's at the booth where
they all no he's in the back smoking
weed with everybody in that back area
gotcha right so he's smoking weed and he
comes in and
I just have this bit about when I was in
Vegas and how uh the the bit's basically
about how uh on Fremont Street security
was tight for
um jelly roll
and the joke is basically where they you
know Fremont streaming want to make sure
that the terrorists don't get to our
wiggers because there's a giant
underground battle between wiggers and
Al-Qaeda it's like Viking it's like it's
like underworld lichens versus vampires
right so I have this joke where I talk
about wiggers and how like wiggers are
the original trans like they're the
first ones to transition and have their
parents freak out and do all this stuff
so I'm doing a wigger joke on stage
right and I get done it CR it's a it's a
weird bit because it crushes right
so I get done I'm getting back and I I'm
talking to Trevor Wallace who I love who
like I love everything Trevor Wallace I
love this new breed of comics all these
guys coming up Matt Rive Trevor wall I
love all those guys they're doing great
work to take a big swings so
I'm sitting in the back talking to him
and here comes Machine Gun Kelly in The
Green Room no I'm I'm behind where the
curtains are right
so he walks to the back
and he just gets him he's right here
and I'm like hey dude how's it going man
he goes oh man you got some funny jokes
dude and I go okay this is weird energy
but
okay cool okay hey what's up he goes
yeah you got some weird jokes you talk a
lot of [__] and I go yeah I do talk a
lot of [__] I go oh is he just trying to
be funny with the comedians
is that what he's doing I but also what
are you doing rolling up and just
walking backstage at The Comedy Store
yeah what what are you doing because
you're you and your world and you're in
your world which this is not this is not
in any way that's like us walking into
the Dugout right now and going hey uh
[__] up with that man I'm down in The
Dugout like uh
man you don't like the hustle huh just
gonna Trot down
you don't care that you could have
gotten that ball hanging over the Dugout
yeah remember I went to the uh World
Series on mushrooms I went and saw the
Dodgers on mushrooms and Puig just tries
to overact like he's gonna he has a
simple gr catch but he over acts it and
drops it imagine if I went in the back
on yo man
why you act why are you putting on
theatrics to everybody just grab the
ball dog yeah like how quickly would I
get punched in the face if I Pleak so
he's in the back and he goes by himself
he comes back no he comes back with one
security guard
so he comes in the back of one security
guard
it comes and he and I can't tell if he's
joking because there's something about
at The Comedy Store and with comedians
that that people want to act like
they're as funny have you ever seen that
like it almost becomes in the hecklers
right when you do like you could break
down why men and women each Heckle one
of the reasons men hackles because their
girlfriends laughing really hard and
they're they're not enjoying it or they
want to be a comedian like they're the
funny guy in their group and they want
to be comedian so they think in a weird
way they're performing so I get that a
lot where like people talk [__] you're
like okay I get it danger this is your
moment so I thought maybe that was it
but I started to realize it wasn't that
and he's literally getting in my face
about a joke and I figured it was the
wigger joke so I just assume
you're just guessing here huh shot in
the dark but that's so
that's what so he's in my face
he's like you look like you talk [__] I
go I talk a ton of [__] [__] and then
they they break it up I'm like so I go
right on stage
it's talking about how Machine Gun Kelly
got my face because I talk [__] I'm like
yeah I'm gonna talk about how you look
like a Hot Topic scarecrow right so I I
do that joke
he's in the back [__] talking me to all
my friends and they're like and everyone
knows he's the GM's guest so like I'm a
crazy person dude
but I'm not an [__] like I'm crazy
but I will always be respectful I'm a
respectful guy so I know he's the guess
the GM and I'm thankful that the comic
store lets me do my show that I really
enjoy doing comedy chaos we've been
doing it for like eight years it's a
blessing I'm gonna show respect okay I'm
not gonna clock this [__]
so he goes in the back they I I walk he
talks [__] on the way I'll I I let him
go okay bro okay let him go it's
Richie's friend he goes in the back
somebody
must have told him
that I lit him up on stage
who's back there rat
you know his buddies so now he comes
back again
uh what happens now he comes in the back
security this time no but now he's got
his crew and it looks like everybody
from Savage Garden
it looks like the guys was having fun I
go this is what your backup is
90s pop rock that's what you're bringing
back here
so he gets in my face he goes why are
you talking [__] go because you're
getting in my face and you don't know
where you are who are you bro I mean I
know who you are but why why do you
think you have any kind of cachet here
dude you got nothing
and that's when my friends start to S to
to Circle everybody starts to Circle
and and Richie's about okay okay and I'm
like dude
if I would have swung on this guy I
could probably sell
20 more tickets in Baton Rouge
I could have sold 20 more tickets
you lose your Cleveland Fan Man
can't go back to Cleveland but I could
crush it everywhere else
it is wild it's wild to think that
because you're someone in your lane that
you can step out of that Lane and go I'm
sure there's a there was a powerful
attorney might have been sitting at a
top Doctor Surgeon in the city didn't
get up and come back like do you know
who the [__] I am in my world and let me
tell you uh hell no and he's a bean pole
bro he's like tall and skinny and listen
I I have nothing but love dog I'm a
lover not a fighter but I will fight if
we have to and I don't want to but man I
was like dude if I swing on this guy I'm
a King Legend but then I love the GM and
like I'll never do anything to
disrespect the shorts at the comedy
store so he goes back in again I leave
this while I go I'm just gonna I don't
wanna cause any problems like everyone's
having a great time
so he's about to leave right and then he
walks right up to me again again
everybody's getting uncomfortable and
The Comedy Store is like come on let's
take a picture let's take a picture
I'm like [__] so he starts doing this
like flip you off thing and I'm like
okay I'll do the flip you off thing as
well so they take a picture of it it
gets put on in on on the internet now
all my conspiracy fans hate me because
they think I've sold my soul to the dark
arts because that's what they think it
and now I have to I have to I have to
put out this fire and now I'm putting
out that fire fires
I'm like I can't I don't really have
anything again like he doesn't resonate
with me at all I don't hate him I don't
wish him a will and I that was right
when his wife booted him to the curb Fox
because he found out he had been
cheating so he's going through a rough
week
if you would came up going hey dude I'm
having a rough week I got ladies
problems like sit down tell me about it
bro but instead you're like in my face
so we took this picture and like oh and
that's it and then ever and then it was
so funny because all these content
creators started telling their version
of the story
and none of it was real so I got to
listen to people like and then I met him
in the kitchen I started throwing Forks
at him
I got I got sources everywhere they say
someone in blackface and got it like
what are you talking about
haha
what are you talking about I can't wait
to do your show next week dude oh dude
it's the best I can't wait so so I am uh
I don't do drugs anymore like I said for
two and a half years I've been very
blessed I stopped doing drugs
um but I have drug Tendencies like I'm
very afraid of cops still so I still
drive down like weird weird places right
like I won't take a regular street I'll
do side streets where I know cops aren't
just so I don't see a cop I see right so
like a lot of times when I left a comedy
store I would go the long way around to
get to where I live when I lived in
Hollywood and the God I'm I'm driving
down the side street and I stop and I
look up and there's a buck naked hot
blonde
from about one block away
and she's super tall but you could tell
from where I am that's an attractive
woman and she is buck naked
and I'm like what is happening here
right
so I'm like I gotta see what's going on
so I drive up
I drive up I roll up
and she turns around and her dick just
starts flashing I was gonna say are we
sure this is a woman here I was about to
ask you like you've got this tiny pecker
with these long balls right
she got these these Click Clacks bro she
got Click Clacks she got truck nuts
you got a little dick and truck nuts
so so I'm like what the [__] and then I
start getting fatherly do you love
rolling what's your pro now
what the hell is he doing right
I wrote down I start going oh somebody's
going through something right now or
running from something or yeah so I
rolled down my window I'm like what are
you doing I start getting fatherly with
a naked trans hooker right there on on
this side street I go what are you doing
I go you don't have to do this you you
don't have to do this you're better than
this you your your your connection I
start getting spiritual with this naked
trans hooker telling her about how we're
all have Christ Consciousness we're all
connected we're all here to do a higher
thing she's like yeah I'm like come on
so I go how about this I'll give you 50
bucks if you put your clothes back on
she's like really so she runs over she
puts her clothes back on I'm like good
you're doing great suddenly this fat
hooker comes up and she goes will you
give me 50 bucks to put my clothes back
I go
but she was chunky
she was threatened enough yeah she was
threatening to take him off will you
give me 50 to keep my [__] on
please leave
don't burn my eyes what's your venmo
let me cash happy
oh
so this trance hooker goes to her tent
puts her clothes back on I go here's 51
don't you feel bad she's like yeah and
now I start feeling like I'm I'm
vibrating on a higher level
that I'm like I'm like oh I'm like I've
done I've done something called
abundance I practice everything so every
day I write down goals I think it's very
important to manifest right right now
every day and night do ya I write down
what I'm thankful for I do it in 369
which is you know the uh Tesla's numbers
of the universe so I do uh nine nine
things I'm thankful for sometimes I
write down the same [__] over and over
again but I do write it down and then I
do nine goals for the day and then I'll
do like if I had time I'll do 27 life
goals
if I have time I'll do nine six
intermediate goals and and 27 life goal
and you'd be amazed man how many of
those things you end up
hitting yeah like it's mind-blowing it's
like just it's just this thing it's
manifestation then the other thing is
um abundance so I think we live in this
world of a bunch of scarcity where they
try to teach you that there's only so
much here there's only so many days
You're Gonna live there's only so much
money you gotta save your money I think
you give it away I think you do like if
you're in if you're in fear you go out
you give 20s to people and it's amazing
how money shows up
so I just gave this naked trans hooker
50 bucks to put her clothes back on I'm
like you know what I feel good about
myself suddenly I hear a little voice
going you know she's Buck Naked again I
go no way
we had a deal
I wouldn't she would never violate our
deal we're friends we're friends
I gave her 50 bucks she would never do
that he goes the voice goes oh she's you
know she's bugging I go no she's not I
guarantee it he goes why don't you go
look I turn around I come back she's in
the middle of the street buck naked
doing [__] naked helicopters right in
the middle of the Ring just where she's
like rolling
I roll up on her I go I thought we had a
deal she goes Girls Gone Wild
I deal with that stuff all the time
so oh God
do we have time for yeah I want to hear
about this uh are you going to say about
the
what you tried to stop oh yeah so I have
two dogs right and you know you have a
dog in the other room and we love our
dogs and but when you live in LA you
have to get your dog these high-end dog
food you can't give them the Kibbles in
bed you gotta get them like I don't know
what makes it high food but you gotta
get high-end dog food and the only place
that sold the dog food that my dogs
would eat is Gelson's okay right so
which by the way if people don't know
Gelson's it is like it's the it's the
OCD grocery store every label's out it's
like it's expensive though you pay for
that except for my new one it's ghetto
Gelson's oh really it is oh no that's
not normal at all you walk in your life
Christine yeah not no that's not normal
at all yo over there there's like a two
chicks fighting like it's some uh
Instagram fight dude
security is by the way security is Just
an Illusion yeah that [__] was going off
on the employees and the old security
guard was just like don't do that
stop it nobody's stopping this chicks
anyways so I have to go to gal since I
go in I grab my my uh my cans of food I
get uh I get my car and I back out
because I I'm a human being I'm not one
of these narcissist piece of [__] who
three-point turns back into it there's
nobody drives me more nuts than people
who reverse back into a parking spot
they make you wait there's like a
special place in hell it's them and the
people who can't wait their turn to get
off of the plane have you ever seen
those people every flight I'm on it's
driving me nuts every flight I'm on and
these days because of my back I'm
sitting in first class and there's
people still running up they run up they
run up because they know no one's gonna
fight them or say anything and they're
already at their destination so what are
you gonna do throw me off first great
I'm out first in any way it's wild
there's no rules wild to me there's no
there's no honor anymore if they just
said there is no standing allowed in the
aisles then people would stop they
should do that they don't do it because
it's ridiculous it is crazy so there's a
special place in hell for those two
people so I I I drive up and I I get my
car I reverse back in I'm about to take
out take off suddenly's cop car flies up
and these two cops get out and they grab
this green gun and I go what social
justice Warrior things going on that you
got a Nerf gun you got a Nerf green gun
and of course I'm I'm a comic so I have
to see what's going on so I pull up and
this is going on in Franklin so I pull
up
and it's this guy walking back and his
Avalanche
of cops got guns on him marching him
down Franklin this is happening in the
middle of the street in the middle of
the street dude
and it's happening right in front of the
Scientology celebrity yeah yeah have you
ever been to that I've never been in but
I used to go to Cafe 101 all the time
yeah that's where all the weird stuff
happens it's a giant castle by the way
for people are trying to convince you
they're not a cult yeah that's the worst
building you could have by the way
so it's happening right there and it's
literally when I tell you it had to be
30 cops with guns marching this dude
down dude one dude hands up he has
something in his hand okay okay
so I'm literally like dude I gotta Stop
This I Gotta save this guy from getting
shot because if he gets shot I'm not
gonna be able to feed my dogs right
they're gonna shut everything down
[Music]
thought about the drama
I get shot over and over in your mind
forever it's my dog's gotta eat man yeah
my dog's gotta eat them
uh so handy God I become what every
black Comics makes fun of white people
about where we run to Danger hand to god
dude I hit the gas I drive around the
cops they're like hey hey I drive around
and I get right next to this dude
I get right next to this dude
and I rolled down my window and I'm like
you gotta get down bro get down and
suddenly I hear it from the side hey get
out there I look over freaking bike cops
are coming at me
like hey fake cops get out of here when
you get a car come down until then get
rid of your big wheel okay and then I'm
like dude you guys get down I look up
he's filming himself by the way which is
a strike one in my book I don't know
what you did to this this is even worse
than filming yourself
and then I look up now all the guns are
pointed to me
and I'm like okay now I'm gonna get shot
and you don't want to be a white guy
who'll get shot
you don't want anybody to get shot no
you don't want a black person get shot
because when a black person gets shot
City Burns legislation changes
White Chicks start slinging [__] right
but whatever
when a white guy gets shot nobody cares
nobody also what a way to go out that'd
be horrible yeah no I'm saying just
being the actual cause of death being
lit up by 30 angry cops who are just
this guy's like a cold anger I'm like
get whatever it is just give it up bro
and he's like shut up and I'm like he's
telling you to shut up you're out there
I'm on your side bro
put down the co-hanger
I've never seen that many cops in my
life so what did you do then I I took
off and they didn't fire or yelling Dude
I kept looking listening to the news to
see if something happened because I was
going to go back and be the witness and
give out my Instagram handle so
everybody could follow me
that was it dude
oh dude I really enjoy talking to you
man thank you for coming and doing this
today I got it dude I'm proud of you
you're a dad and you're a sound like
you're a good dad and you want to be a
good dad that's that is the most
important person but I'm trying I love
my kids love your kids be there for them
support the stuff they want you to
support even if you have to fake it fake
it till you make it act like you love it
that's all they care about I have uh I
have a saying and that is bills are paid
kids are happy life is good Bingo that's
it
um promote everything one more time
please uh I am Sam tripoli.com get all
my dates there you can watch I have I
have eight podcasts and uh I think I set
the record and you can get them all at
samtripley.com and if you want to hear
every week I just go out like and lay my
life on the line to see what the
craziest [__] I could find is and then I
talk about unbroken Sim and uh if you
like some of these stories this is what
I do every week go to find broken
simulation Tim full hat Conspiracy
social club Union of The Unwanted
they're all there and uh I do hours and
hours and then if you really want I do I
have a uh I have a um uh premium content
that I do on rockfin.com that's
rockfin.com and uh I have three shows on
there and I do three episodes a week on
the Tim full hat uh so I do a uh uh AMA
then I do uh we break down old footage
old shows all that stuff and then I do
an interview so if you get three
episodes a week on rockfin.com
there it is thank you brother I love you
buddy I love you so great and I love you
so much you're one of the G's good to
see you doing wonderful [__] you too
brother uh and I'm looking forward to
your show next week as always Ryan
sickler.com Ryan sickler on all social
media go get your tickets come see me on
tour Ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign